you
want to ask questions ask them and so
please be quiet so you could hear the
answer
that's why we're here tonight we asked
them to come we didn't
have to ask them to come remember that
so we're asking everybody please keep it
civil two minutes to three minutes times
it's a long it's a big meeting there's
gonna be a lot of questions and it's
gonna be a lot of answers
so we're asking everybody to please keep
it cool okay
promise me thank you
yes sir uh i know is that right uh the
muslim american society
said in getting a lot of attention in
the national media the major expose in
chicago tribune
which demonstrated that it was the
foremost
arm of the whistle brotherhood in the
united states the muslim brotherhood
according to a document that was
revealed during the holy land
finance foundation holy men's foundation
terror financial trial in 2007
is dedicated in its own words to
eliminating and destroying western
civilization
from within and sabotaging its miserable
house so that allows religion remains
victorious
you can find it on youtube
to bring islamic law to the united
states in ways in which it is
yes robert spencer from g-hotbox.org
that's jihadwatch.org
uh
so why did the brotherhood
okay
american society is an independent
american islamic organization that aims
to move people for god consciousness
liberty and justice and convenience time
with arthur's clarity
and in face we're not changing the
history it says towards the beginning of
the 20th century
muslim brotherhood evolved in many arab
movement countries the foreign
muslim brotherhood became the only
substantive movement
that only found itself in opposition
oh
groups in our country are either
fairly small or entirely secular
enhanced or extremist
violent
of the members of the brotherhood who
traveled to europe and the united
states early in the 60s as the students
and those who who had an active
inclination were influenced in one
another
by the ideology of development they
participated
in finding many senate organizations
1993 that is
in 1993 the establishment of mass
was a declaration of an american muslim
agenda a worldwide organization that
related
to the united states of america to
accommodate the needs
of the american muslim political
muslims
and any foreign
is
according today
foreign
do you wanna yeah a relationship with mr
gray